these are worms not the kind of worms
you find crawling in the dirts these are
parasitic roundworms they live inside a
human beings intestines
each of these worms can grow up to 12
inches long and there are 200 of them in
this jar for a reason because that is
the number you might typically find in
the belly of a single infected child
worm infections have been around for
thousands of years they have influenced
the outcomes of Wars and they have long
stymied human health roundworm hookworm
whipworm schistosomiasis infections from
these species cause pain and discomfort
they steal nutrients and zap energy the
stunts both physical and cognitive
growth in most cases these worms may not
be fatal but paradoxically that's part
of the problem it means that many
countries simply have not been able to
prioritize their treatments there's a
social cost to that children without
access to deworming treatments have
lower rates of school attendance adults
who grew up without deworming medicine
are less productive and have lower
lifelong earnings what intestinal worms
do really is limits potential currently
there are 1.7 billion people in the
world still at risk for worms 600
million of them are in Africa for every
dollar invested in worm control and
prevention African countries see up to
$42 returned in economic benefits the
good news is that deworming treatment is
extremely easy one to three pills given
once or twice a year is enough to take a
child from 200 worms to zero and to
protect them from infection going
forward in communities where there's a
high prevalence of worms treatments can
be done right at school this process is
extremely simple and fast in Ethiopia
for example this is done for 20 million
children in a matter of weeks the world
has come a long way on getting deworming
medicines to the people who need them
and African governments want to gain
more traction it's now time to match
their ambition the end fund will work
with governments to create a plan that
drastically reduces the burden of
disease caused by worms they'll work
together to ensure prevention and
treatment programs can serve everyone
the end fund has an audacious idea they
believe we are the generation to end
sickness from worm infections forever
the key is not simply to build new
programs from scratch
but to amplify the efforts of the
programs that are already taking shape
by examining the problem of how worms
transmit disease the end fund has
identified five key areas where they can
drive improvements number one lower the
cost of treatments many pharmaceutical
companies offer deworming medicines for
free so the end fund works with the
right partners to coordinate their
delivery they will continue to secure
drug donations for additional at risk
populations they can now do it for less
than 25 cents per child per year number
two
focus on prevention the end phone calls
in the right partners to educate
communities on sanitation and hygiene in
order to change behaviors around things
like hand washing and latrine use
ensuring people are not continually
reinfected number three invest in
innovation the end fund has contributed
to deworming by introducing innovative
techniques that effectively targets and
treat people they will test new delivery
methods target the environments where
parasites thrive and influence behavior
change number four monitor and evaluates
the end fund collects detailed data on
all programs on a regular basis to help
them get better and better over time
number five increase local ownership at
all stages of the process the end fund
works with government and local
stakeholders to encourage co-financing
commitments that supports deworming
efforts they also work with African
philanthropists and corporate leaders to
partner on these efforts there's an
incredible opportunity to work together
to create a new system for disease
elimination for the next decade and
beyond part of the money the end fund
needs will go directly towards
delivering deworming treatments to
communities that need it and parts will
go towards facilitating the handover of
programs to local ownership together
these efforts will create prevention and
treatment programs that are sustainable
far into the future if this plan gets
fully funded for the next six years tens
of millions of people will receive
deworming treatment with that countries
will be interrupting the cycle of
disease transmission at all levels and
most importantly people will experience
significant improvements in their mental
physical and social health
just imagine the potential that will be
gained when people can stop worrying
about these
can put their energy into things like
these
[Music]
[Music]